foreign
's with us in St Louis hi Madeline
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
I am losing faith
um excuse me
I just feel like this is never going to
end this debt is so big
and and I'm just I'm frustrated and I
want to do with that pre-scream so bad
and it just it feels like it will never
come how can I keep going
how long you been in this Madeline
well off and on for like five years but
we've been gazelle this whole year we
have decreased our debt by 80 000 this
year way to go it feels eighty thousand
in one year
we my husband we had saved a bunch my
husband had a great paying job we've
been working hard both of us but I just
don't know that I can do this for
another two years potentially hmm how
much debt have you got left
we have 221 000 in student loans and
her mortgage is not in the intense set
so you've got the 221 to deal with what
do you guys think we currently have 221
in student loans
I do mine alone we paid off my husband's
this year just last month actually very
good what do you all do for a living
I'm a chiropractor I'm self-employed and
he's a nurse
so what's your household income
last year we
um grossed about
250. what will you make this year
he is in between jobs and so and my
income fluctuates and that's the hardest
part why is he in between jobs he's a
nurse
he um he they did away with his one job
that was very well paying so now he's
waiting to hear for another job that is
a local travel so that he can be home
every night how long has he been waiting
um he just applied this past week he
accepted a position he's waiting for a
religious exemption to go through so he
does not have to get vacuum ing
how long has he been waiting
um two days how long has he been out of
work
and he's not currently out of work he's
working weekends part-time right now
until he
gets anything happening so okay so the
facts are that he hasn't lost much
income
no okay so the facts are you guys are
going to make 300K this year
we hope to no there's no reason you
shouldn't no
no you are
okay yeah
you can't let uh you know all these ifs
ands and buts the the fact is you got a
job and of course your income fluctuates
you're self-employed but that didn't
change
and the fact is he's a nurse which means
he can get employed in about 30 seconds
and he just proved that
yes yeah so the fact is you're not in
trouble at all you got stinking 300 000
potential income it's amazing way to go
and you've been guilt you said you've
been gazelle intense for one year right
um just this year actually just the last
couple of months oh so you're gonna be
right on track from the point of you
getting gazelle intents you're gonna be
right on track with everybody else who's
you know debt free in 18 to 24 months
okay so I'm I'm
um
a little bit confused or something that
you're not telling us
well I want to know about the she said
they've been at this first you know I
think you said four or five years but
you just got intense I want to know
about those years what was going on with
that
my husband just got on board this year
we we started Financial Peace at the
beginning stop stop saying here's what
I'm struggling with and you need to help
me okay
you make 300 000 a year
your husband's got a new job
and you have 221 to go you've just
proven that you can do 80 000 in what
period of Time how long did that take
about four months good God yeah okay so
we just did 80 000 in four months and
four months is not exactly I'm out of
steam and I've lost hope I don't
understand where this the tears and the
I'm not saying you shouldn't have them I
just don't understand where it's coming
from why would you be hopeless you
should be like Rocky right now you paid
off eighty thousand dollars you make 300
you should be like doing a touchdown
dance I know so what where's all this
where's all this hopelessness come from
we had a kind of an unfair Advantage we
sold our truck we sold we we really just
like went hard as soon as we took the
financial piece we sold the truck we had
a little in savings that's what gave us
that's what you're supposed to do at the
beginning I'm not saying you can
maintain 80 over four months but we know
we can maintain 150 over a year yeah
if you make 300 and you lived on 150
that'd be 150 towards debt in a year
which you can do in your area
yes it feels like I'm giving my lifetime
and I'm stronger
hey you better yeah
you better give your life to it no no I
know hold on hold on hold on here it is
you're tired from before
you retired from before trying to get
your husband on board and and you're
letting that make you tired now but that
was gone that's in the past and now you
guys have a new lease on life he's on
board he's on the plan you did you got
intense you paid off eighty thousand
dollars and don't forget what I just
told you now you're just like everybody
else you're on the 18 to 24 months plan
you can live on 150 and put the other
150 on your debt and you're gonna be out
of this in no time this is the walk
there's not an easy button to press uh
Madeline this is the walk there is
sacrifice there is you do feel tired I I
can't you can't wave a wand and get out
of that part but um there is real hope
absolutely I mean if you can't be out of
debt in 24 months making 300 and you
can't pay off a hundred a year 150 a
year for two years and be done in 24
months I I mean we somebody needs to
come smack you you need to do this this
is doable the math is doable
this is not hopeless at all when you
started this I thought you were going to
tell me you made 22 000 a year and owed
400 I didn't know this way it sounded
but this is not hopeless at all the math
on this is easy yeah but it's you I mean
yes you're signing up for a pain in the
butt 18 to 24 but at least you'll be
free forever when you finish forever yes
you can do this
okay this is really really doable but I
think Jade's right is she right you're
tired from before not from now
yes
yeah because this last go-round you
hadn't done enough to be tired yeah no
she was pulling him up the hill before
she was rolling a a a pushing a mountain
I'm dead nurse weight yes that's what it
was but he's on board now hooray you
guys are you guys are finally doing the
one together now to the extent that he
is not on board or you're not sure he's
on board that would give me pause I
would be hopeless then
I would be crying then
because if you got to drag him all the
way through this you may not get through
it you've already figured that part out
right
I think it's just we I know this is the
beginning of a very long you know it
feels the day feels so long yeah how old
are you doing 18 31. do you have kids
what were you doing when you were 29 do
you even remember
no okay it's two years ago
yeah two years in the scope of your
life's not spit yes it's going to be
hard but yes it's going to be worth it
and yes it's doable and the time is
gonna pass anyway and that's the
question you have to ask yourself are
you going to wake up a year and a half
two years from now and you can wake up
two years from now and be in the exact
same spot you're in now or wake up two
years from now and be finished and
that's where you need to put your mind
imagine waking up two years from now
Madeline having decided it's too hard
we're not going to do it and you still
got 221 more because it's student loans
and the interest is going to come back
and it's going to tally up so here's
what's happening right this second Jade
and I can see this math and are more
excited for you than you are for you
yes right this second I know that's what
we're trying to translate for you we're
trying to zip some of that excitement
over on your side of the aisle yeah
because you need you need a little zip
of that and we love you we want you to
win yes you're signing up for two years
of hard or if you don't do it you're
signing up for 20 years of hard yeah
we're yelling at you
and we don't want you to I can see tap
out I can see it very clearly that where
you're going to be if you and your
husband both stick with this you both do
beans and rice rice and beans you stop
the vacations in the eating out we have
job one and that's evict this ugly old
woman from your house named Sallie Mae
she needs to go she's got a wart on the
end of her nose she's a she's a she's a
squatter in the bedroom she needs to go
we need to throw her on her can in the
street
that's where she needs to go and it's
War baby it's War
and you need to declare war and get
energy out of that and kick that old
woman out you can do it the numbers say
you can do it so put all the past tired
behind you embrace the 18 to 24 war and
get her done you can do this